welcome back to the game SWAT stage here
at e3 2015 it's day three but that
doesn't mean we've got a shortage of
games to show oh no we have got Batman
Arkham Knight and joining me on the
couch here we've got Sefton hill from
Rocksteady games hello and Ian who is
the lead so what was your role the lead
designer and the game director so you
know the guys to talk about Batman
that's on your business card as soon as
you brought the live gameplay demo for
us so we can see the game in action yeah
do I want to hop in yeah let's do it
let's jump right in we'll show you the
size and spectacle of Gotham City right
there
it's pretty this is running on the
PlayStation 4 yep and one of the big
things we were going for is to create a
world with all of the detail and rich
richness and love that we had in the
previous game and a much bigger scale
than ever before you can see diving
right in you can see how much texture
and life there is in the world yeah it's
a really big thing for us obviously
introduced in the Batmobile as well is
the other big key feature we're showing
and you will be playing in that all week
so you see here streets are really
populated with thugs the story is
basically the Scarecrow's threat in the
city city with a chemical weapons attack
and it's part of a ploy from all the
supervillains working together to take
down Batman so they decided following
the death of Joker at the end of Arkham
City spoilers if you haven't played it
by now first of all what are you doing
exactly you deserved it if you hadn't
peddanna yeah so the game follows those
events and following the events of
Arkham City you've got this period now
where the supervillains are all with the
removal of Joker that chaotic fact has
gone and they've decided if we're going
to get rid of the bat once and for all
we all need to work together so this is
a coordinated attack by all the
different super villains on Gotham City
which is why it's populated by all of
these gangs that have moved in following
the evacuation yeah so what are we gonna
be seeing today so right now we've just
seen a little bit of action a little bit
of gliding yeah I understand you guys
going to be showing off
something that we've never seen in
Arkham night yeah that's right yeah
we're going to show off one of the crime
scenes that are around the scene so it's
going to jump from the car you can see
anyone near the car gets blown away this
is the Most Wanted will which is a
really important part of the game
because this is where you select what
you want to do one of the things that
cash has told you about is that there's
a mysterious body in the city so when
you go to GCPD you meet Aaron cash you
meet Gordon and they'll tell you about
this mysterious body that the forensics
team or the police discovered they
didn't have time to investigate it was
just really strange so Batman's going to
go and investigate this crime scene
world's greatest detective has to do
some grunt work exactly you need to do
some hardcore detective work it's always
been a big feature in the Arkham games
the detective side so this is a bit of a
murder mystery if you like those whose
bodies planted around oh that was it
that was really nice sort of like using
the momentum of the Batmobile to sort of
propel yourself forward that yeah that's
a huge part of the game is kind of
mixing up the car and the gliding and
perfecting those two skills together
yeah so here we have this body here
Batman's talking back to Alfred if you
see there's writing on the floor as well
that's a serious body that he finds
investigate let's check it out and the
game is fairly dark to be honest because
because it's the culmination of all
three games because it's kind of epic
conclusion I mean that's the thing about
Batman is it yes he's a superhero
but really in the dark the sense of the
word in that Gotham is not like the
airy-fairy kind of oh you know save me
save me it's you know it's it's a
cartoon it's a comic but it's dark yeah
you have to read so I mean some of the
comic books especially I just get two
really really weird
dark twisted places yeah I mean a lot of
our inspiration comes from there so just
while Ian's looking at this as he's
scanning around the body he's looking
for clues you can see the scanner that
he has can look through different layers
so he's looking through the material at
the skin layout saying strange about the
ears so Batman's going to scan that and
identify what's wrong with that
and what's happened here is he's found
the body all the distinguishing features
of the body have been stripped off so
he's now looking for a way to identify
who this is you see on the left side of
the screen there's two thousand matches
for the ear deformity for that specific
ear deformity and Ian scanning around to
find if there's any other elements of
that body which are going to narrow down
and allow Batman to sort of pinpoint who
this is so we've gone through the skin
level and now we're sort of really going
into the deep tissue yeah that's deep
tissue now and a muscle will out of the
deep tissue layer and then we can go
more in go one layer further than that
as well and actually look to the bone
you can move between those three layers
looking for clues like I swallowed a
ring so you swallowed a ring yeah that's
part of his story and you'll unravel the
story of these victims throughout the
city and you're looking kinda for what
interconnects them there's a serial
killer loose in Gotham so can I pick up
this mission like at any point or yes
triggered by certain story mission yes
so basically one of the great things
about moving to you know next-gen I call
it next-gen current-gen now is all of
these things exist concurrently in the
city so anytime you want to go and
investigate you're going to come across
things like this actually if you listen
carefully here again it's not like we
talked about before there's this really
distinctive opera music playing and as
you're moving through the city if you
hear that opera music that's a good
indication that there's something around
to find and you'll kind of use that
audio clue to track this down yeah and
actually you would have seen on some of
the trailers we released before some of
the gameplay trailers you would have
heard as Batman was gliding around the
mission carefully a little bit of opera
music kicked in and that's a clue as to
where some of the victims are just
quickly I mean I don't question it but
while they were going through our
database who are those people is that
the development team family or it could
be me could be Gotham City residents so
where is the investigation taking us now
so basically we have a number of bodies
around the city he's gonna have a look
to see if we can find any others but the
great thing about the Batmobile is where
it can go so it's not like any other
normal car so we're going to investigate
up here see we can jump across even onto
the roof of this train station see
there's ramps around here
it's the great thing about the car is
the way it's so maneuverable and
different to any other vehicle you've
played in any other game switching into
battle mode there to kind of really just
get that turn yeah so if you look at how
tight the movement is across here battle
mode allows you this really precise
movement smashes through objects and
allows you this very precise specific
movement throughout the city yeah so
it's something really different and then
you can go back instantly between battle
and pursuit mode yes because it's just
holding down alt o to at any time
see there's loads of Secrets around the
city as well so if you go out come up
here you bring the car up here you need
the car to blast through these walls so
lots of the secrets require you to use a
bit of the car and a bit of Batman as
well and even the remote control in a
Batman so the remote control in the
Batmobile allows you to use those two
separate entities to solve loads of
these puzzles will show you something
else really cool here with the Batmobile
so just briefly saw there Edward nigma
obviously not one to be a bit lazy and
just let other people cause trouble
leaving stuff around the city he's got
his Riddler race tracks as well yeah
where he's just determined to get one
over on Batman yeah we can show you a
bit of the race tracks as well if you
want to see a really cool move here is
it attach the grapple to a building up
you can actually drag the car up the
side of the building to again I don't
notice that we've ever shown it's a
really cool feature that you have to
sort of think about the car very
differently to any other vehicle because
it's so multi-purpose because it is the
only vehicle you get to use so we wanted
to make it the best vehicle I guess in
any game ever that was like our
challenge that we set ourselves over the
fast like how big is Gotham City now
compared to I guess the like the annex
of it that we saw in Arkham City yeah so
Arkham City was big Gotham City is five
times at least five times the size of
Arkham City and while keeping that same
density of detail and care and love in
each in each square meter so as you can
see here the richness of the level it's
again it's something that could only be
done PlayStation 4 Xbox one you know
it's saying that can only be done on
these new
of concerns see everywhere we go look at
the textures on the ground richness you
mentioned about Riddler we can even less
we're right here now we can go in and
have a look at what Riddler's got ya
around for us so we have these he's
basically challenged Batman to come to
these different areas
yeah fight actually with this one if you
come here early and we were talking
before about how everything exists in
the city concurrently if you discover
this for yourself and if you're watching
this video you'll get a good idea of
watching us man you'll get a good idea
of where to go you can come here before
Riddler's even ready for you oh and
he'll give you a little chance to play
this first track before he's even
actually set up what what are the big
stakes for the day which he explains all
a little bit later so alright so we're
just descending down into the sewers now
yeah completely seamless so everything
in the game is seamless there's not a
single loading screen in the whole game
yes start to finish and that's really
important for us too well as well
because what the world to have that
lovely coherent consistent feel every
time you hit a loading screen it it
takes you out of that in hmm but you're
playing a game so I mean there's no
point in trying to like be the Batman I
guess if you're constantly pulled out to
a screen and you remember that you're
yeah you're playing a game and game
loading units and everything so we push
that even further than we've ever done
before seamless streaming throughout the
whole game so feel like we're being
lectured a little bit maybe Riddler's
take you making fun of us and now this
is the racetrack yeah so these are
Riddler's challenges and some of them
are more racetrack challenges and some
of them are puzzles where you have to
hang the bat the build well I'm going to
point them some of the really intricate
puzzles where you're using both this is
the very first one so it's kind of an
introduction and you'll see how it
develops and evolves as you race around
as well so Riddler's basically taunting
you he'll use any opportunity to try and
taunt you he's to get in get in your
head all the time and actually the
Riddler story in the game again without
giving too much away so I think that
it's really interesting where that goes
he has a bigger role that he's ever had
before
and it's a lot more than just collecting
the trophies there's a whole art but
Riddler has cuz he's always sort of been
on the
oh yeah not really directly causing
chaos but taking part in it and now it
seems like he's really getting into the
oh yeah he's getting his hands dirty
this time I mean he's hell-bent on
revenge for those who played through to
the end of Arkham City and actually got
to the the final Danu Mont of Riddler's
arc you'll know that riddle is really
annoyed and really wants payback for
what happened at the end of that game so
he's gone to a really extreme lengths to
get his revenge I really wonder how he's
funded all this seems like going in
there like an over-enthusiastic way we
do actually explain in the game partly
how he even built these huge
constructions and he's had a little
mechanical help it would be fair to say
so that's how he's built these crazy
huge contraptions and you can see as
Ian's playing through here how the
levels manipulating and changing as he
races through and every lap he does it
gets more and more difficult so what
would happen if I were to fall if Ian
were to fall off right now yeah so what
happens if you do crash here we go I
will show you we do a very quick reset
to get you back in so we don't punish
you it's just you lose a bit of time
because it's all against the clock but
boom you get to go again very quickly
yeah it's important thing that we want
to keep it generous you know big thing
for us is making sure everyone gets to
enjoy the game as well and then the more
you play that obviously the harder it
gets and some of the later richer
challenges are really really tough some
of the toughest stuff we've ever done in
the whole game so we see here we're on
how quick you've got to go through these
things you see the floor detonates below
Ian's here we need to kind of ride over
the top of the loop oh my god do you
remarkably well you need die once that's
because I told you do he's played it
once or twice before I much I feel like
I drink that yeah so driving along the
wall switching and then the last big
challenge to hit the last big ramp yep
move the wall out the way midair so that
wall
skip that out of the way but then put
the landing platform back in perfect you
see we've got more waynetech points
upgradable trees let's talk a little bit
more about that because that's a great
thing about Batman is that he has all
these abilities all these great gadgets
all these things that he can use in his
arsenal to take down everybody in Gotham
yes I am showing you a little bit of
this here this is the upgrade system and
you can upgrade the Batmobile the
Batmobile weapons combat the bat suit
there's a ton of upgrades in the game
more than we've ever done before
and you can if you go back to Batmobile
someone at the Boyar here's some of the
coolest ones if you go one down into the
afterburner recharge you've also got the
ejects 1up you don't quite have enough
up rode upgrade points for it the eject
is one I definitely recommend you get
soon because it allows you to fly a
Batman even higher up out the car and
just glide and transition from being low
down in the street so I above the sky is
great and every mission you play every
most-wanted mission you play gives you
upgrade points so if you're hunting down
scarecrow and you feel like you need a
helping hand if you feel like you want
to upgrade the Batmobile or Batman then
go and do some of the most-wanted
missions you can quickly boost that
Batman when you play through but it's
not only the Scarecrow or Riddler that
we have to worry about there is a new
adversary in town and one that you guys
actually came up with yeah let's talk a
little bit about the arkham knight yeah
so the arkham knight it's a huge
privilege for us to be able to create a
new character in this universe it's
someone who we wanted to compliment
scarecrow because scarecrows the
psychological threat he wants to tear
apart the myth of Batman and Batman
psyche but to do that he needs some
muscle you know he needs someone who can
confront Batman as a physical opponent
so the arkham knight is that he's
someone who commands this huge militia
force this huge drone army and the two
of those team up together or what
provides such a tough challenge for
Batman and it's kind of a it's sort of
strange in the sense that although it's
our most epic game ever it's by far the
biggest game we've ever made with the
most content we've ever made the story
is our most personal story we've ever
told
an attack on everything it means to be
Batman they want to destroy the myth of
Batman so it's a very much a I'm not
sure all that Arkham City we went for a
pound of it ensemble cast
yeah and for this it's a really focused
dedicated attack on everything it means
to be the Batman so it's you know--since
an epic game but there's quite a lot of
the Arkham Asylum DNA yeah in this game
as well I mean one of the things that we
haven't really seen in Arkham Knight
obviously the game down in a couple
weeks I is the claustrophobic predator
room style gameplay but you have got
things like the fear take down yeah so
we know that those elements definitely
though in there yeah yeah and it's one
of the things that we've kind of wanted
the players to experience themselves
quite a lot because they're so dynamic
and those things change every time you
play and that's actually something that
the Arkham Knight really brings to the
party is that we have an adaptive AI
system and as you play those rooms he
studies the tactics you use if you're
doing silent takedowns he'll tell his
guys to buddy up if he sees you moving
around in floor breaks he tells these
guys to start mining the floor breaks
and search in the floor great so if you
use a tactic too much he notices that
and starts counteracting your tactics so
you have to kind of switch your tactics
dynamically as you play and one of the
things with that left so the enemies are
also more aggressive they also have
sentry guns they deploy so if they
detect that you're doing too many
takedowns in an area they would employ a
sentry gun to block that off to try and
make you switch things up that reminds
me of the the excellent I mean it's one
of my favorite boss fight ever is of
course the mr. freeze boss mode and you
can't use the same thing twice yeah I
believe I know what's gonna happen here
this is an example of your dual play
yeah that's right so we have Nightwing
here as well so one of the big things is
Catwoman Nightwing and Robin fighting
alongside all three of those at
different points of the story night
wings working with you taking down
penguins weapon caches so you get these
great jewel team moves take em out in
midair
yeah when you do the jewel team moves
you switch between the characters as
well
yes so nice to be able to like welcome
these faces back again as playable
characters yes so this is the first time
they've been fully integrated into the
story as well so previously what we've
done is we've had them in challenge maps
but now seamlessly as you saw here Ian
drop straight in through the skylight
into this penguin weapons cache and
immediately Robert Nightwing joins in
and the two of them are fighting
alongside and so and you'll be get that
dynamic system of moving between them
throughout the game and it adds a new
element it's definitely still about man
game yes so like that's the key thing
it's all about Batman and it's about the
way Batman interacts with these other
characters but getting to play them and
get into cool light Batman working
alongside them is a big big part being
Batman right of course
well septillion thank you so much for
bringing arkham knight on to the games
on stage when is the game out because
it's really soon yeah that's right one
of the great things is III are nobody
waiting a year to play stuff right well
this is out next Tuesday June 23rd
wonderful thank you guys so much guys
make sure you stay tuned here at the
game's foot stage at the e3 more awesome
demos coming right up